this morning russia in the united states
are squaring off over new american
sanctions imposed after an assassination
attempt on a former spy in england using
a nerve agent moscow says they're
unacceptable and illegal the sanctions
prohibit a wide range of exports to
Russia they'll take effect August 22nd
if Congress does not object major
Garrett is near the trump National Golf
Club in New Jersey where the Presidents
on vacation
major good morning good morning there is
a Washington backstory to this move on
sanctions Edie Royce he's a California
Republican has for some time been
demanding the Trump White House use a
1991 US law meant to punish countries
that use chemical or biological weapons
well after months of inaction the Trump
administration finally moved in part to
appease Royce and also if possible quell
electioneer accusations of going easy on
Russia it certainly looks like the
Russians were behind it more than four
months after accusing the Kremlin of the
nerve agent attack that poisoned this
Russian born British spy and his
daughter something the russians deny
president Trump will now hit some of the
top oligarchs and businesses with close
ties to the Russian President only weeks
after praising Vladimir Putin as he
stood by his side in Helsinki I called
him a competitor and a good competitor
he is and I think the word competitor is
a compliment and again just days ago I
got a little great with him but now more
chill in the relationship between
off-again on-again rivals with the most
aggressive White House sanctions yet
that could block Russia from purchasing
potentially hundreds of millions of
dollars in weapons electronics and
avionics we want to have open lines of
communication the action came the same
day Kentucky Republican Senator Rand
Paul hand-delivered this letter from
President Trump to Putin asking for
expanding dialogue discussions are
incredibly important diplomacy is
important other top Republicans had
slammed the president for not standing
up to Russia if you were really tough
with Putin he would not be doing what
he's doing
even after mr. Trump pushed back on
critics with CBS's Jeff Glor you have
people that said you should have gone up
to him
you should have walked up and started
screaming in his face we're living in
the real world the president met with
Senator Paul in the White House to
discuss his agenda for this Moscow trip
and approved the letter of introduction
Paul gave to Putin and the White House
is drafting an executive order that may
impose sanctions if someone has found a
foreign national that is guilty of
meddling in the midterm elections as for
these sanctions Vlad there could be
another round in 90 days if Russia
doesn't take steps to verify it will not
use these kinds of weapons again so
major let me ask you this president
Trump's legal team has responded the
Special Counsel Moeller's proposal for a
presidential interview what do we know
about their counteroffer well I just
spoke to Rudy Giuliani the president's
lead attorney on this and he now
describes himself as more optimistic
than he's been in weeks and there can be
a resolution that could lead to an
interview between President Trump and
the special counsel Robert Muller
apparently the two sides have narrowed
their differences over what can and
can't be asked and Giuliani told me that
there's at least a 50/50 chance that
that interview could happen sooner
rather than later all right major
Garrett thank you very much